So what I'm about to show you are my
methods for doing these things
they may not correspond exactly
to what Rich Sutton did.
So keep that in mind but
I've used these methods in practice and
found them to work really well.
Let's start with Learning T.
Remember T of SA S prime
represents the probability
that if we are in state S, take action
A we will end up in state S prime.
To learn a model of T.
we're just going to observe
how these transitions occur.
So in other words we'll have experience
with the real world we'll get back
on s, a, s prime and we'll just
count how many times did it happen.
So I'm going to introduce a new table.
I call T count or TC.
And it goes like this.
So we initialize all of our T count
values to be a very, very small number.
The reason for that is later on you'll
see that if we don't do that we could
get in a situation where
we have a divided by zero.
Then we begin executing Q learning.
And each time we interact with the real
world we observe, s, a, and s prime.
And then we just increment that
location in our T-count matrix.
So every time we see it transition
from S to S prime with action a,
boom, we add a one.
And that's pretty, it's pretty simple.
That's it.